that men on that man so Ben Affleck who
is apparently still Batman for now might
not be Batman for long you're basing
this on all of a reporter article that
ran yesterday yeah yeah I think it was
Friday speculating that Affleck was this
Justice League was the last time that
you'd see Ben play Batman right
hey I'm what he's happy about Oh
somebody's unhappy it's it's there was a
it seemed come out of well no no not
nowhere he did back away from directing
it and they have since changed course
with the script and I'm using the script
I mean we talked about that when that
news first broke like if he's not
directing the Batman I don't think he
stars in the Batman because if you've
got to build a bat universe around a
dude you don't want to be 50 years old
as Batman it seemed like an we I think
we had talked about the time like all
right it's a slow exit you know like
they're not they're like don't quit the
movie you know directing it and and
acting in a G's let's do this in pieces
so suddenly it felt like oh yeah I guess
this is the last piece I mean weird
timing because like he's got to come
here and sell Justice League at
comic-con then cut to today where he
comes out on stage for the Hall H
presentation and kind of turns the story
around says something the honor of the
quotes but something effective like that
Batman is the greatest character I think
he cursed [ __ ] character on the
planet and I loved playing him or
something like that the thing is
whatever he said I read it and it didn't
necessarily dispute the hallowed
reporter article he didn't say I'm not
going anywhere you know it's just like I
love Batman to a room full of people
like yeah
I farted in the show to shoot his mind I
don't even say that I'm wondering if you
know it was an it felt like a non-denial
denial you know what I'm saying and did
I read it wrong did you even rape people
right I mean and and I also wonder leave
a grip on the quote you tire you look at
it this is how this works and also I'm
wondering if they also talked about like
finding a graceful exit for been as
Bruce Wayne right now do you think and
do you want them to kill Bruce Wayne no
because they're gonna kill Captain
America what I mean guys come on
now they're killing Captain America I
absolutely have a hard-on for the shot
of Captain America dead on the on the
steps of the whatever the [ __ ]
Capitol building
are you is that a fan theory I mean
that's what happened in the Winter
Soldier books and they're all about that
they are absolutely letting toward the
place where you know cap will go rogue
he will come back in he will be the hero
once again and that is when you kill
America's greatest hit soldier who kills
him Thanos to the Infinity Gauntlet I
mean it had been look out [ __ ] I'm on
the edge of my seat you don't even know
I'm making this [ __ ] up like what could
it be I don't know the closure goes not
only like here take my money we better
our tickets fast to this movie that
doesn't exist I mean if I'm making this
movie Black Widow kills him oh you
[ __ ] cold
what Wow at danos controls or at danos
them something huge has to kill [ __ ]
Steve that's not of this earth and it
should be him and we watch the fight I
hate getting in these conversations
because it's like all this shit's made
up but we watched them fight iron man
and stuff like no mortal was going to
take down Captain America it's going to
take a mad Titan from space tours going
to take somebody he trusts implicitly oh
[ __ ] you're smart dude
goddammit that's [ __ ] smart man but I
also like the Batman is bigger than any
one actor yes you know and there's no
real [ __ ] we had an in continuity Batman
changed nobody gave a [ __ ] we're like
Michael golf is still Alfred but
suddenly it's Clooney and then suddenly
it's Kilmer or vice versa cuz I forget
when that happens but we don't care
ultimately it's Batman I want to see
hold on here's the quote ready coming
from Ben Affleck himself clearing rumors
slash current stories quote I am the
Batman I have the coolest job ever
unquote I mean if you like eight but who
I say when I say who it's I mean it's
really just a kind of sounds like a
humble brag I am the Batman I have the
coolest job ever
I am those are present tense I am the
Batman for my whole today I have the
coolest job ever until I walk away from
this [ __ ] you know what I'm saying he's
still covered and remember there it
wasn't long ago I think it was last year
they were like they're gonna he's going
to direct the Batman movie and then a
couple months later like he's not
restoration so I don't know what do you
think many tickets for real do you think
he's doing it I mean I think it's for
real I think if they're going to
continue especially if your quote so
thank you thanks to [ __ ] Twitter we
could listen to Ben Affleck's own words
here we go
[Applause]
I'm so thrilled to do that that's
related drug rehabilitation [ __ ]
amazing and history 300 kids Gemara
scroll I don't never doesn't mean you
know I believe it with memories doing it
like I feel it from a tree how about you
what I really blown away excited and a
great time in the DC Universe I just I
[Music]
mean honestly like that's that's not
like I'm [ __ ] locked and loaded
they're gonna have to pull my [ __ ]
dead ass out of the Batcave I'm my hands
are on my bat-pole from now until the
end of time as a guy going like hey man
shit's nice now sure is nice to be here
you know I don't know if there's I don't
know we'll see that's already Ross is
building a bat universe around that girl
and you're gonna have the Gotham City
sirens and you're going to lean into all
this
yes I think you start over I think you
start cleaning you start fresh you make
a whole new sucking thing does I mean do
they even have to do anything like me
just change if you're gonna change about
man change Batman it just keep moving
forward you like it bond can do it then
that make it and then make a joke about
it two stories down the line about like
you know how member Martha shut the [ __ ]
up and move on
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]